president Trump declares executive
privilege over the unredacted mela
report president Trump's tax returns
from three decades ago spell out and
Democrats escalate impeachment talk I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
separation of powers fight separation of
powers fight I know it's such exciting
stuff when the president of the United
States declares executive privilege in
order to shield his Attorney General
from possible impeachment Wow things are
getting so exciting for people who
really love talking about the legal
vagaries of executive privilege we'll
get to all that in just a second first
for a few weeks now I've been reminding
you Mother's Day is fast approaching did
you listen you did not now it's just
days away so what are you gonna do I
have an answer for you 1-800 flowers
it's here to help you pick out a
gorgeous bouquet it will show your
mother that she is loved even though you
have been remiss up till now right now
when you order a dozen multicolored
roses for just 2999 1-800 flowers we'll
give you another dozen plus a vase
absolutely free that's 40% off the
original price okay let me just tell you
1-800 flowers it is a fantastic gift
it's so good all of the flowers are
beautifully presented they last forever
I get my wife flowers every time I go
out of town which means I get my wife
flowers a lot 1-800 flowers is the place
that I go this gorgeous bouquet of two
dozen roses in a rainbow of colors is a
perfect surprise she's guaranteed to
love roses are the perfect way to
surprise all the moms in your life wife
sister grandma these breathtaking roses
from 1-800 flowers are picked at their
peak they're shipped overnight to ensure
freshness a dozen multicolored roses for
only $29.99 plus another dozen and a
vase for free it's an amazing offer but
you have to hurry because it does expire
on Friday crust 1-800 flowers to make
mom feel loved ordered today from 1-800
flowers calm to order a dozen multi
colored roses plus an extra bouquet and
a vase for just $29.99 go to 1-800
flowers com / Shapiro's that is 1-800
flowers calm / appear oh this fantastic
offer does end on Friday so make sure
that your mom is taken care of in your
wife grandma everybody 1-800 flowers
calm / appear oh okay so the rubber now
meets the road the rubber now meets the
road the President of the United States
this morning declared executive
privilege over the unredacted Muller
report so here is the report from the
New York Times they say president
Trump's asserted executive privilege on
Wednesday in an effort to shield hidden
portions of Robert Muller's unredacted
report and
the evidence he collected from Congress
so to recapitulate William Bott wrote a
four-page synopsis of Robert Muller's
report he then released the entire
report with certain sections blacked out
the sections that were blacked out there
was not a lot of accusation that this
hid super-secret really bad stuff that
was going to end in president Trump's
impeachment it looked well just
politically speaking it looked as though
Democrats were trying to shove into the
redacted portions all of their
expectations that were unfulfilled in
the actual model reports they expected
from the mollow report damning evidence
of obstruction of justice damning
evidence of collusion and conspiracy and
none of that was in the actual
unredacted Mellon report there was some
bad behavior by the President of the
United States there are some ugly
behavior by the President of the United
States there was nothing that rose to
the level of criminally prosecute Abul
behavior even according to Muller
himself who declined to say whether the
president should or should not be
prosecuted kicked it over to Attorney
General Barr who said I don't have the
evidence to prosecute here so Democrats
instead of saying okay well melody Denis
thing Barr didn't do anything
we're done here instead Democrats said
you know what
probably the material that we've seen
does not merit impeachment right this is
the implicit the implicit acknowledgment
of the Democrats putting all of their
expectations on the rejected sections of
the report is that they are implicitly
acknowledging that the unredacted
sections of the report are not enough to
sustain any sort of impeachment push so
instead what they did is they said well
probably the redacted sections that's
the part that's nefarious that's William
bar hiding material from us from us and
William bar was like well no the reason
that stuff is hidden is because it
impacts ongoing investigations number
one or number two
to release it would violate the federal
rules of Criminal Evidence because I
cannot just release grand jury
information into the public view and
also we have no responsibility to turn
over grand jury information to the
legislative branch of the legislative
branch wants to do its own
investigations they can subpoena any
witness they want and bring that witness
to them so long as the president doesn't
assert executive privilege over that
witness now from the democratic point of
view they're saying okay well here's the
deal we want to talk to robert muller we
want to talk to john McGann the
president's personal attorney we want to
ask them questions that we feel were
unanswered in the Mullen report and they
should come and they should sit before
us and hopefully we can
right out of them some evidence that is
impeachable because the report itself
doesn't include that and President Trump
is saying guys we've just gone through a
35 million dollar process here resulting
in a 450 page report if it ain't there
it ain't there and subjecting people who
worked for me or people who are members
of the executive branch to more of your
questioning that will just generate more
headlines that will end in nothing all
of this is just Machiavellian
manipulation so this is where we end up
with Constitution 5 2019 because the
question is what can the presidents
assert executive privilege over the
Democrats have no subpoenaed the full
Muller report they want all the
unredacted sections they even are asking
for the grand jury testimony and William
bar is saying I can't hand that stuff to
you because to do so would be a
violation of my obligations under the
law to protect people who have not been
accused of or convicted of any crimes
who are not being tried for any crimes
it would be to subject them to scrutiny
unwarranted by law which is a proper
position and Democrats are saying no if
you won't hand us that material then we
are gonna hold you in contempt and bar
says fine then I'll just ask the
President of the United States to assert
executive privilege and then I don't
have to turn it over and you can't hold
me in contempt because you have no cause
to hold me in contempt because you can't
legally get those documents so that is
where we stand this morning the
Democrats pushing for some sort of
contempt hearing on William Bar they
were gonna push forward for that this
morning and the President of the United
States declared executive privilege over
these documents now this looks a lot
like what happened with Attorney General
Eric Holder in fast and furious so there
are a bunch of documents in Fast and
Furious Fast and Furious was a scandal
that happened during the Obama
administration I know there were no
scandals during the Obama administration
you've been told by the press that of
course is a lie the Fast and Furious
scandal was the DOJ working together
with the ATF to allow guns to be bought
by straw purchasers in the United States
and then smuggled south to Mexican drug
cartels where they would be used and
then presumably we would we would track
where the guns went and this would help
us uncover the chain of weapons
provision to the Mexican drug cartels
some of those guns were then used in the
killing of Border Patrol Agent Brian
Terry and this became a national scandal
so Congress investigated and they
investigated Holder and they said did
you give the explicit go-ahead to the
ATF to allow illegal sales of weaponry
that you knew was going
to be smuggled to Mexican drug cartels
and that you could certainly foresee was
going to be used in the murder of
American citizens Eric Holder then asked
the president then Barack Obama to use
executive privilege to shield him from
the exposing of documents Congress
proceeded to hold Eric Holder in
contempt that executive privilege
contention by the Obama administration
ended up being overturned by a judge
those documents eventually were turned
over and it turned out that the
documents didn't really show anything
supremely damaging beyond what they
originally knew so the the here's the
problem executive privilege is really a
vague category of law it's really vague
there's not been a lot of judicial
rulings on executive privilege executive
privilege was only formally acknowledged
by the Supreme Court of the United
States in 1974 there's nothing in the
Constitution that explicitly says
executive privilege exists but there's
also nothing in the Constitution that
says that the executive power has to
bend before every subpoena of
legislative power there is a balance of
power and there is gridlock so the idea
of executive privilege does have long
roots in English common law it's not
just an invention that's been made up in
the last 50 years or so so this is where
we stand then I will get into the
analysis of whether executive privilege
applies here because there are a couple
of different types again information
first opinion always comes after so the
New York Times reports that mr. Trump's
first use of the secrecy powers as
president the executive privilege
they're now calling secrecy powers came
as the House Judiciary Committee is
expected to vote Wednesday morning to
recommend that the house hold the
Attorney General William bar in contempt
of Congress for defying a subpoena for
the same material now as I've been
saying for a while I think that this is
all a game for Democrats I don't think
that they actually care about the
underlying material I think they're
looking for an excuse to blame William
Bar and cast him as an instructor when
in fact there's no evidence that he's
obstructing anything at this point
let Justice Department officials Stephen
Boyd wrote on Wednesday morning this is
to advise you that the president has has
asserted executive privilege over the
entirety of the subpoenaed materials by
released a redacted version of the
special counsels 448 page report
voluntarily last month Democrats say
that is not good enough they've accused
the Attorney General of stonewalling a
legitimate request for material they
need to carry out an investigation into
possible obstruction of justice and
abuse of power by mr. Trump and Barr
says well listen you are the ones buying
votive candles
Muller he didn't recommend an indictment
I looked at his report you looked at his
report if you want to impeach him go for
it
I'm not prosecuting him because the
evidence does not sustain that and
that's where we stand the House
Judiciary Committee prepared to vote
Wednesday morning to hold Barr in
contempt despite that threat issued late
Tuesday night from the Justice
Department many Democrats and they did
not take kindly to the department's
threat they said in the coming days I
expect this Congress will have no choice
but to confront the behavior of this
lawless administration says Jerry Nadler
now the Trump administration says what
the hell are you talking about we let
Muller to go through all of his paces
here we spend 35 million dollars he's a
member of the executive branch the
President of the United States could
have fired him at any time at any time
and the fact that he did not and let the
report go forward the fact that time
again did speak for hours on end to
robert muller and that Muller
interviewed him and Muller I promise you
is a better interviewer and a better
lawyer than anybody who's on the House
Judiciary Committee and the House
Oversight Committee and why are you
suggesting that Robert Muller did an
insufficient job but Congress is going
to do a wonderful job and if you think
Robert Muller did an insufficient job
well then subpoena of the witnesses
yourself don't do this routine where you
use his underlying materials and then
suggest that he was too foolish to
understand the materials had already
compiled Sarah Huckabee Sanders has
released a statement she says the
American people see through chairman
nailers desperate ploy to distract from
the president's historically successful
agenda and our booming economy neither
the White House nor attorney general bar
will comply with terminate enablers
unlawful and reckless demands the AG has
been transparent and accommodating
throughout this process including by
releasing the no pollution no conspiracy
no obstruction Mellon report to the
public and offering to testify before
the committee these attempts to work
with the committee have been flatly
rejected they didn't like the results of
the report and now they want to redo
faced with German nailers blatant abuse
of power and at the attorney general's
request the president has no other
option than to make a protective
assertion of executive privilege it is
sad the Chairman Naylor is only
interested in please in pandering to the
press and pleasing his radical left
constituency the American people deserve
a congress that is focused on solving
real problems like the crisis at the
border high prescription drug prices our
country's crumbling infrastructure and
so much more there's a lot of truth to
this there is no evidence that the
redacted material is going to be
providing Nadler and Democrats what they
want here
seems like a manufactured controversy it
does seem like a manufactured
controversy now does the president
actually have the power to assert
executive privilege over all of this
material we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about something
we can all agree on saving cash the
reality is if you're not shopping around
you're probably not saving money so what
if there was a way to do for somebody to
do the shopping around for you well
that's basically what honey does honey
is a free tool that you download to your
computer's browser and then while you
shop online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts then
automatically applies the coupon with
the biggest savings to your cart a
checkout like magic just runs in the
background of your computer it works on
over 20,000 sites from Amazon to nords
from j.crew Nike Best Buy Nordstrom
Target Macy's and more Nordstrom twice
guys it takes a zero effort to install
just two clicks and you're ready to
start saving any time you shop online
there's really no reason not to use
honey we use honey in our home all the
time because we buy stuff from Amazon
basically all of these sites I just
mentioned we use honey on it's free to
use and install to on your computer in
just two clicks don't take it from me
take it from our listeners get honey for
free and join honey calm slash pen that
is join honey calm / ban honey is the
smart shopping assistant that saves you
time and money
again it saves you time and money and
you're doing it like it's a it it's
nothing I mean you're not spending money
it just runs in the background a
computer and checks out the prices and
gets you savings on virtually and the
huge number of purchases at least go
check them out right now at join honey
calm / banthas join honey calm / ban
okay so the do js letter to Jerry Nadler
is worth reading info it's not very long
this letter was written by Stephen Boyd
the Assistant Attorney General here's
what he wrote we are disappointed that
you have rejected the DOJ s request to
delay the vote of the committee on the
judiciary on a contempt finding against
the Attorney General this morning by
doing so you have terminated our ongoing
negotiations and abandon the
accommodation process with respect your
April 18th 2019 subpoena of confidential
Department of Justice materials related
to the investigation conducted by
special counsel robert muller as we have
repeatedly explained the Attorney
General could not comply with your
subpoena in its current form without
violating the law court rules and court
orders and without threatening the
Independence of the Department of
Justice's prosecutorial function despite
this we have attempted to engage with
the committee in good faith in an effort
to accommodate your state
interest in these materials
unfortunately rather than allowing
negotiations to continue you scheduled
in unnecessary contempt vote which you
refuse to postpone to allow additional
time for compromise all of this is true
by the way accordingly this is to advise
you that the president has asserted
executive privilege over the entirety of
the subpoenaed materials as I indicated
in my letter to you last night this
protective assertion of executive
privilege ensures the president's
ability to make a final decision whether
to assert privilege following a full
review of these materials so it's
effectively a prophylactic assertion of
executive privilege the president will
declare executive privilege and then
they will analyze what can be released
and then they will release what they
think they can regrettably you've made
this assertion necessary by your
insistence upon scheduling a premature
contempt vote Stephen Boyd assistant
attorney general and all of this seems
right now the problem for President
Trump in all of this is that the
president has made it look as though he
actively wants to stop people from
talking to Congress so the president has
said that he doesn't want Muller to talk
to Congress and that is a problem again
because bars case is not that nobody
should talk to Congress bars cases I
came before Congress I testified before
Congress I revealed as much of the
material as I could legally speaking and
then you guys want me to release
material that is that is not releasable
right you guys want something from me
that I cannot give to you and that is a
perfectly plausible case a case in which
I basically agree with William Barr I
haven't seen the unredacted materials
but I think that he would not commit
perjury by going in front of Congress
and then saying the unredacted materials
are actually I mean that the redacted
materials are actually not necessary to
redact I don't mean that he commits
perjury on that score the problem is the
image here so the image here is that
President Trump is now asserting
executive privilege this is what the
press wants to push the press wants to
push the image that the President of the
United States is actually asserting
executive privilege
not because Barr asked him to in order
to prevent Barr from violating the law
and in order to prevent a contempt vote
that is empty meaningless and
politically motivated the image that is
being drawn by the press and by
President Trump in many reports right
now is that Trump just wants to stop
Congress call
in its investigations and that image is
being painted by stories like this one
so yesterday before the president
asserted executive privilege the
president started tweeting out that he
didn't want robert muller to testify
well there's no reason Robert Miller
shouldn't testify before Congress
there's no legal reason that Robert
Muller can't testify before Congress now
I understand the president being
irritated I do
I'm irritated I find all of this
annoying I don't think that Muller is
likely to give Democrats anything they
want I don't think that Muller is going
to go before Congress and say you know
secretly I wanted to indict the
president but publicly I just sort of
decided to skip it because I don't think
the Democrats are gonna get that from
Muller I understand the president being
this is dragging on forever this is just
another sham by Democrats in order to
prevent us from moving forward with my
agenda I have a lot of sympathy for the
president's position on that but it
looks as though the president's is
trying to stop Muller from talking
publicly because he's afraid of what
Muller is going to say not because he's
irritated with Democrats and this has
been a consistent problem for president
Trump now he fired James Comey the
former FBI director because he suggested
that James Comey would not simply say he
wasn't under investigation and that
annoyed him but for the press it was
because he was afraid of what James
Comey might find same thing here
he's irritated the Democrats are asking
well our questions he's like guys we
spent 35 million dollars he had 40
lawyers on this thing it produced a 450
page report why do you need to talk to
Muller now other than some ginned up
controversy that makes no sense so screw
it not gonna do it right that's what the
president is thinking the way the press
is playing it is Muller is gonna testify
to something deep and dark and perverse
and Trump is super afraid of that you
can listen to this New York Times piece
from yesterday when President Trump
declared that Special Counsel Robert
Muller should not testify before
Congress he contradicted Attorney
General William bar who had already told
lawmakers he had no objection to letting
Muller talk to them that clash has
raised the prospect of a major test of
Justice Department independence on bars
watch defying mr. Trump would be awkward
for Barr in part because he has long
subscribed to a sweeping theory of
executive power under which Trump may
rightfully override and control any
discretionary decision by a subordinate
executive branch official well yes this
is called the unitary executive theory
and it happens to be the case they say
while the Trump team has been pleased
with mr. bars handling of the Mallory
station disregarding Trump's desires
risks angering a mercurial president who
turned on once favored subordinates
including mr. bear's predecessor former
attorney general Jeff Sessions mr. Barr
citing his age and lack of further
aspirations promised Congress during his
confirmation hearing I will not be
bullied into doing anything I think is
wrong by anybody whether it be editorial
boards or Congress or the president I'm
gonna do what I think is right so as I
say the press is playing this as though
Barr wants Muller to testify and Trump
doesn't want Muller to testify because
he's afraid of what Muller will say and
that is followed up by this report that
President Trump doesn't want Don McGann
to testify so again the President does
have the ability to assert executive
privilege with regards to internal
communications with the White House
Counsel obviously with that said McGann
already testified in front of Robert
Muller having McGann go in front of
Congress he's not gonna hurt the
president McGann knows how to handle
himself he knows what his testimony will
be he doesn't want to be seen as either
lying to moe he has to repeat his
testimony basically verbatim right
because either he lied to Muller in
which case lying to the FBI is a crime
or if he would be lying to Congress in
which case he'd be committing perjury if
he did not match his testimony and his
testimony has to match Trump again is
irritated that Congress is calling
McGann he doesn't want to rehash all of
this again but the press is playing this
as though Trump is afraid of McGann
spilling the beans on him so CNN
reported yesterday the White House has
instructed former White House Counsel
Don began not to comply with the
subpoena for documents from the House
Judiciary Committee Jerry Nadler teeing
up the latest in a series of escalating
oversight showdowns between the Trump
administration and congressional
Democrats McGann's decision not to
comply with the subpoena could push
Nader to hold McGann in contempt of
Congress just as he is currently doing
with Attorney General William bar
Kneedler issued a subpoena to McGann for
documents and testimony related to the
committee's obstruction of justice
investigation sending a Tuesday deadline
from again to turn over the documents
and proposing a May twenty first hearing
date needler threatened McGann again
with being held in contempt if he failed
to appear in a letter sent to z'
day-night he said I fully expect that
the committee will hold mr. McGann in
contempt if he fails to appear before
the committee unless the White House
secures a court order directing
otherwise he said a letter from the
White House in service of the
president's apparent goal of blocking or
delaying tests
that the President believes would be
politically damaging is not a basis from
again to violate his legal obligation to
appear before the committee the White
House said it would not allow him again
to turn over the documents the White
House has not related to position on
whether it would seek to block McGann's
testimony to so again there's two
plausible reasons that Trump doesn't
want McGann to testify or turn over the
documents one is I'm done with this this
is a waste of time at Mullen looked at
all of this crap what are you people
doing not gonna do it
McGann sit down shut up that's possible
reason number one possible reason number
two and this is the one the Democrats
are relying on his Trump doesn't want
Muller to talk Trump doesn't want McGann
to talk
Trump doesn't want Barr to talk he
doesn't want any of them to talk or send
over the documents because there's
something hidden now the reason I think
theory one is more plausible than theory
too the reason why I think that Trump
doesn't want these people to testify or
turn over documents is because we've
already had a Muller investigation that
Muller investigation resulted in a four
hundred and fifty page comprehensive
report with minimal redactions if there
were no report at this point I would say
yeah it looks more like a cover-up then
it looks like the president being
frustrated with rehashing the past but
the reports public we've all read the
report Muller wrote it Barr released it
time again testified to Muller so this
is just a rehash I think that this is
the president once again acting
frustrated why because this is always
this is always how he has been he has
always acted frustrated with the
investigation because he feels he is
innocent Democrats are playing that
frustration as the president trying to
engage in a cover-up so they say the
reason he's asserting executive
privilege is not because he's irritated
or he's within his rights the reason
that he's doing all of that is because
he's trying to cover up evidence of a
nefarious crime just like Richard Nixon
if the difference is that Richard Nixon
actually engaged in an underlying crime
there's no evidence that Trump engage in
an underlying criminally prosecute Abul
behavior and number two Richard Nixon
tried to obstruct the equivalent of the
Muller investigation itself he fired the
special prosecutor Archibald Cox he
fired his own Attorney General in order
to do so that would've been the
equivalent of Trump firing Muller and
firing the AG in the middle of the
investigation Trump didn't do either of
those things so the attempt to link
Trump asserting executive privilege to
Nixon asserting executive privilege as
some have been trying to do today I do
not think that comparison holds it looks
much more like President
a certain executive privilege on Eric
Holder maybe and even then I think it's
more plausible that Obama was trying to
hide documents to protect Eric Holder
then that Trump is trying to hide
documents to protect William bar in a
second we'll talk about how effective
this assertion of executive privilege is
likely to be first let's talk about a
quick fact you want to look like a
million bucks
you want to look awesome you want to
look like James Bond you can't just get
a generic off-the-rack suit you need to
get a made-to-measure suit Indo Chino is
the world's most exciting
made-to-measure menswear company they
make suits in shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort if you're in the middle of
planning wedding they have tons of
options for those looking to outfit
their wedding party
I love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and colors to choose
from not to mention the option to
personalize the details including your
lapel lining pockets buttons writing
your own monogram here's how it works
it's just awesome I've done it myself
you can visit a stylist at one of their
showrooms Indo Chino has over 40
showrooms in North America alone they
will take it your measurements
personally or you can measure at home
and shop online at Indo Chino com choose
your fabric design customizations simply
submit your measurements with your
choices online relax while your suit
gets professionally tailored and mailed
to you in a couple of weeks this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 379 bucks at Indo Chino
comm when you enter Shapiro's a checkout
that is 50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure premium suit plus
shipping is free
that's Indo Chino com promo code Shapiro
for any premium suit for just 379 bucks
and free shipping
it's an incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit once you go custom
you don't go back you're gonna love your
premium made-to-measure suit from Indo
Chino comm go check them out at Indo
Chino common use promo code Shapiro to
get any premium suit for just 379 bucks
plus free shipping pretty awesome deal
ok so is the President of the United
States likely to succeed in his
assertion of executive privilege well
here's some of the background on
executive privilege this comes from the
Brennan Center which is a more
left-leaning legal Center doing doing
legal analysis as these heuk was a
columnist I guess over there for them a
lawyer for them he wrote this going back
to 2007 this was not designed for
President Trump or against President
Trump and here's what it says the
president's constitutionally based
privileges
subsume privileges for records that
reflect one military diplomatic or
national security secrets this would be
the state-secrets privilege so the
president is negotiating with China
Congress subpoenas those records Trump
says no okay to communications of the
President or his advisors the
presidential communications privilege
three legal advice or legal work that be
attorney clients or attorney work
product privileges so presumably he
asked Tom McGann for legal advice that
is not subject to congressional
oversight and finally the deliberative
processes of the President or his
advisors the two most commonly invoked
executive privilege Azhar the so called
presidential communications privilege
and the deliberative processes
privileges privilege the presidential
communications privilege protects from
disclosure any communications that are
either by the president directly or by
his immediate advisers in the office of
the president to the president the
Supreme Court did recognize this
privilege in Nixon versus United States
and Nixon versus administrator of
General Services the Nixon cases were
about Nixon being subpoenaed by Congress
for records of his internal
deliberations over Watergate basically
including the including the Watergate
tapes including the Oval Office tapes
and the Supreme Court ruling that he had
to turn them over the court grounded the
privilege and the need for cancer an
executive branch decision making and the
supremacy of each branch within its own
assigned area of constitutional duties
in the Nixon cases the Supreme Court
applied the term presidential
communication privilege solely to
communications involving the president
so the president is talking with
somebody and he wants to keep that
communication secret that falls under
executive privilege however the DC
Circuit caution and not every
communication with a presidential
advisor would be protected the privilege
should apply only to communications
authored or solicited and received by
those members of an immediate White
House advisor staff who have brought in
significant responsibilities so in other
words the janitor at the White House
doesn't have executive privilege once
properly asserted by a qualified person
the presidential communications
privilege applies to documents in their
entirety
it covers final and post decisional
materials as well as pre pre
deliberative ones critically it covers
any factual matter containing a
communication and in this regard sweeps
broader than the deliberative process
privilege which we'll get to in just a
second but the presidential
communications privilege can be overcome
by a sufficient showing of
so if this codes to court expect that
Congress will simply assert that they
have a sufficient need because they are
involved in a criminal investigation and
they need to see these documents one of
the first judicial recognitions of an
executive branch secrecy claim was
written by Chief Justice John Marshall
he endorsed the idea that the privilege
is defeasible in other words however
well-established the privilege may be it
has never been absolute the Supreme
Court has strongly suggested that the
presidential communications privilege
must yield whenever a coordinate
branches constitutional role is at stake
Nixon the Nixon case concluded that
President Nixon had to yield to a
subpoena to preserve the function of the
courts under article 3 another Nixon
case held that Congress could roll back
a former president's privilege in light
of the scope of Congress's broad
investigative powers so Congress says
this particular piece from the Brennan
Center ought to be able to overcome the
presidential communications privilege in
any instance that it exercises its
constitutional powers to legislate and
conduct oversight so the question will
be is this legitimate oversight that
Congress is attempting to engage in or
is this basically political posturing
and that will be that will end up in
court then there is a broader and more
powerful deliberative process privilege
the deliberate process privilege
according to the courts is distinct and
different from the presidential
communications privilege it protects
executive branch officers communications
that are pre-decisional and a direct
part of the deliberative process a
document is pre-decisional if it was
generated before the adoption of a
policy and reflects the give and take of
the consultative process in other words
President Trump is having a conversation
with Don McGann about what to do about
the Muller report and it's before a
decision has been made so that seems to
fall squarely within that privilege the
privilege has long been recognized by
the Supreme Court the underlying
rationale is that the disclosure of
deliberative communications will chill
future communications like Trump will
never talk with his lawyer ever again
thus diminishing the effectiveness of
executive decision making and injuring
the public interest now properly invoked
the deliberative process privilege is
narrower than the presidential
communications privilege primarily
because the deliberative process
privilege does not extend to purely
factual material unless it is
inextricably intertwined with
policymaking processes in other words if
there is an investigation it in covers
factual material that's not a
deliberative process privilege
deliberative process
began offering his opinion on the
underlying materials it doesn't
necessarily cover the underlying
materials themselves it's also
susceptible to congressional or judicial
negation the privilege disappears when
there is any reason to believe
government misconduct occurred so will
this assertion of executive privilege
hold up in court if the president tries
to assert executive privilege over all
of us only if the court having looked at
the actual privileged material which it
will only if the court having looked at
the material finds that Don McGee that
don McGann was involved in legal
discussions protected by privilege or
looking at the unredacted mela report
finds that william bar is speaking the
truth and that this material could not
simply be released into the public in
reality this is more of a delaying
tactic than it is a legal tactic
designed to keep these documents secret
in reality I think the courts would be
likely to rule against the Trump
administration on executive privilege
grounds as they did by the way when it
came to executive privilege for Eric
Holder and President Obama now here's
the truth there's a long history of
presidents using executive privilege
that in and of itself is not impeachable
Democrats have been trying to claim that
the president because he's asserting
executive privileges in indubitably
trying to hide something as I said
there's a very plausible alternative
theory where he's just frustrated and
annoyed and where Dan McGann where Don
McGann doesn't want to commit perjury by
by accidentally miss answering a
question or where William bar is trying
to prevent himself from committing some
sort of federal crime by violating the
federal rules of Criminal Evidence
that's a plausible theory a court will
end up sorting this out suffice it to
say that the assertion of executive
privilege alone in this particular case
does not necessarily mean a nic Sounion
cover-up we get some more of this in
just a second I'll talk about the
differences between various types of
exertions of executive privilege
historically speaking first every night
I try to fall asleep there days when
anxiety and stress keep me awake no
matter what I take what I do it doesn't
help I'm not great at sleeping but I've
now been trying calming comfort by
sharper image it's a luxurious weighted
blanket it helps you relax so you can
fall asleep and stay asleep naturally
and I'm a tosser an eternal calm and
comfort blankets help prevent all of
this they are designed with high density
come
for Phil to provide exactly the right
amount of weight to help relax your body
in mimics the soothing feeling of being
hugged for less stress and a restful
night's sleep
maybe with supersoft Velveteen material
designed to promote a sense of calmness
and relaxation for a more restful sleep
it's a it's a weighted blanket
that I mean let me tell you it does feel
as though you are being basically combed
into sleep it's really well named wake
up feeling refreshed when under the
blanket you experience the great feeling
of being hugged calming comfort applies
and even amounts of pressure over your
body to help the production of serotonin
and melatonin simulating deep touch
pressure stimulation calming comfort
it's a hundred percent machine washable
and dryer safe the common comfort
weighted blanket comes with a 90-day
anxiety free stress-free best night's
sleep with your life guarantee from
sharper image so what do you have to
lose right now just for our listeners
you can go to common comfort blanket
calm use promo code been at checkout to
receive 15% off the displayed price
again that is calming comfort blanket
calm promo code been because you can't
put a price on a great night's sleep go
online now at calming comfort blankets
calm and use promo code Ben for that
special discount today it really is not
only supremely comfortable it does help
you sleep better go check it out right
now calming comfort blanket and again
they've got that it's gonna be awesome
where he get to return it guarantee so
what do you have to lose comon comfort
blanket calm use that promo code Ben for
the special discounts today okay more on
executive privilege and where this is
going plus a supposedly blockbuster
report I'm president from not being good
at business
Oh God him that's where they're moving
now we'll get to that in just a second
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire calm and subscribe when you
do you get the rest of this show live
you get the two additional hours of us
every afternoon I mean we are working
our fingers to the bone for you you need
to help us out by the way helping us out
becoming a subscriber it's one of the
things that also prevents prevents tech
companies from cracking down on us if
they disagree with our basic politics it
also prevents all sorts of manipulative
actions by our political enemies
subscribing is the best way to support
us I get letters all the time how do we
support the show best way to do it go to
over to daily wire comm and subscribe
for $9.99 a month for 99 bucks a year
you get this the greatest in all
beverage vessels look at this thing the
leftist Cheers hot or cold tumbler
magnificent magnificent go check that
out right now
also please subscribe at youtube or
itunes we have so many great sunday
specials coming
for you let me tell you I mean I'm eager
to tell you the guest list it's great
you're gonna have to go check that out
at YouTube or iTunes and then subscribe
if you want to get those a day early
on Saturday and see our special material
behind the paywall with all of those
guests pretty awesome stuff go check us
out we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so I want to go through a brief history
of the use of executive privilege so we
can see how President Trump fits in with
precedent so we'll start with Richard
Nixon because the prior invitations of
executive privilege were a lot less
controversial obviously and Nixon is the
one who people are trying to compare
Trump to here I don't think that the
comparison is apples to apples for a
bunch of reasons as I will explain the
Constitution Center has a really good
summary of all of this
they say executive privilege had always
been nominally used in defense of the
public interest Nixon attempted to use
it to protect himself and other advisors
during Watergate in the landmark Supreme
Court case us versus Nixon the Supreme
Court unanimously declared that
executive privilege is constitutional
and sometimes necessary for national
security but the court also held it is
not all encompassing if requested
documents and testimonies are key part
of an investigation they must be brought
forward
therefore the Watergate tapes were
turned over to the special prosecutor
shortly after this decision Nixon
resigned because he was trying to stop
those tapes from coming out because they
showed that he had engaged in criminal
activity according to the Constitution
Constitution Center Nixon forever
changed how Americans view executive
privilege his questionable use of the
power led many Americans to believe that
all uses are for the same undisclosed
reasons this may have led Gerald Ford
Jimmy Carter Ronald Reagan George HW
Bush to use the privilege sparingly
especially Ford Reagan was so cautious
he didn't even use executive privilege
during iran-contra the next controversy
regarding executive privilege came with
Bill Clinton the Clinton White House was
mired in two scandals whitewater and
Monica Lewinsky during those
investigations President Clinton used
executive privilege 14 times 14 times
that included protecting First Lady
Hillary Clinton from testifying
during the whitewater hearings and
protecting himself from testifying in
both of those cases his executive
privilege claims as well as his attorney
client claims in the Lewinsky
investigation were challenged in federal
court citing US vs. Nixon the courts
determined that the prosecutors needs
outweighed the confidentiality of
executive documents and discussions this
ruling was not appealed to the Supreme
Court the White House sought to avoid a
headline-grabbing
legal loss Clinton of course ended up
being impeach Barack Obama used
executive privilege during fast and
furious as I mentioned ATF the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms had run an
operation to sell guns to Mexico trying
to track the guns one
guns was eventually used to kill Border
Patrol Agent Brian Terry representative
general Isum and Senator Chuck Grassley
held hearings to determine what went
wrong during the mission Obama and AJ
Eric Holder both said they didn't know
about the mission until a few weeks
prior to the killing and didn't
authorize it Congress and the DOJ ended
up in a standoff over the sharing of
1,300 documents leading Obama to assert
executive privilege in order to keep
them private Congress voted to hold
holder in contempt Obama's claim of
executive privilege was rejected by a
federal court so as I say the chances
that this is held in that these
executive privilege attempts hold up are
pretty low unless William Barr is
telling the truth and this material
simply cannot be released because this
material is would violate federal rules
of criminal evidence right so if Barr is
lying then the executive privilege will
be struck down all of this will end up
in the hands of Democrats which means
will become public if William bar is
telling the truth then a court will
adjudicate that an executive executive
privilege will have been properly
applied now the way Democrats are taking
that is that a mere assertion of
executive privilege amounts to a
cover-up as I say I don't think that's
correct just as I don't think that the
president's mere firing of James Comey
amounted to an attempt to stop the
Moller investigation I don't think that
the president merely discussing with Don
began that he wanted to fire Muller
amounted to a firing of Mahler the
president is a volatile human being the
president is a guy who doesn't like
being bothered he doesn't like being
under scrutiny so there's a very
plausible explanation from not wanting
Muller to testify or McGann's testify
there's a plausible explanation for Barr
asserting executive privilege here and
even those are not for the same reason
right Trump doesn't I don't think Trump
really cares whether the unredacted
material comes out in the bar in the bar
version of the report the redacted
report
I don't think Trump cares about the
underlying material because again the
report has found what it found Barr
found what he found and we're done there
I think Barr is really I've seen no
evidence the bar is dishonest in other
words I keep hearing from Democrats that
bar is dishonest I don't see evidence
that bar is is acting dishonestly here
to cover for the president this seems
manufactured to me on the bar front that
said the president has a unique gift
for making innocuous headlines seem non
innocuous and so instead of just saying
listen my Attorney General says
Democrats are seeking material that he
cannot publicize without violating the
law so I'm asserting executive privilege
at the same time he's saying I don't
want Muller to testify and I don't want
McGann to testify he should just say
listen what I prefer that these guys not
testify sure I'm annoyed with this whole
thing but if Democrats want them to
testify they'll come forward and testify
we'll do this whole thing again if the
President had been a little more client
during this entire process it would have
served him a lot better
instead by thrashing around and
struggling it makes him look more guilty
than he actually is because I don't
actually think that he's guilty of a
crime here well this has left it to
Republicans to explain senator Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader he
points to the Democrat said these people
are not serious him Muller is done this
is not a serious party seriousness is
not what we've seen from the Democratic
Party in recent days not serious what
we've seen is a meltdown an absolute
meltdown an inability to accept the
bottom line conclusion on Russian
interference from the special counsel to
report okay and then he continues by
saying listen this this investigation is
that Ned Miller is done so what exactly
are you doing here
and of course McConnell is right about
all of this that doesn't mean that
Congress doesn't have a inability or a
duty to investigate if they want to
investigate they can so McConnell was
right on the substance I think that in
process is that the Republicans would be
better off they're saying listen all the
doors are open you want to interview
whomever you want go for it can't give
you these documents cuz that would
violate the law but you want to
interview my lawyer you go on an
interview McGann go for it William
Barty's showed up and testified before
adults and made you look foolish I think
it would look more like the same from
Muller and McGann but here's McConnell
rightly saying listen this Muller thing
is done in Democrats really we all know
what this is about Democrats trying to
dig scandal out of non scandal I told
everyone there'd been a conspiracy
between Russia and the Trump campaign
yet on this central question the special
counsels finding is clear case closed
and then Democrats of course have
responded to all of this by saying no no
no no the reason that Trump doesn't want
Muller to testify or McGann to testify
is because he wants a cover-up because
Trump wants a cover-up here Chuck
Schumer and Senate Minority Leader
talking about all of this
375 former federal prosecutors looked at
the Muller report and said publicly that
the conduct of the President amounts to
felony obstruction of justice and that
in any other case where he not president
those prosecutors would recommend
bringing charges so our leader says
let's move on it's sort of like Richard
Nixon saying let's move on at the height
of the investigation of his wrongdoing
of course he wants to move on
he wants to cover up he wants to silence
okay so this is the Democratic take on
all of this is that reality is this
really about silencing no but it's not
smart of the president to grant the
impression that the press would like to
push forward that he would like to cover
things up again there's no underlying
crime that's been uncovered here as far
as that letter from prosecutors saying
that they would have prosecuted
President Trump
sure he would have yeah I'm sure again
Muller's people wanted to prosecute the
president is obvious when you read that
report
Muller's people despise drum there's no
way to read that second half of the
report about obstruction and not read
prosecutors struggling to death
to try and catch Trump's in in something
prosecutable and not quite being able to
and having to let it go all these
prosecutors they're not prosecuting
Trump so it's easy for them to say yeah
I'd prosecute him if I have that sure
you would sure you would a meanwhile
Democrats are trying every other Avenue
to try and humiliate President Trump the
latest example is of course this large
report in The New York Times that back
in the 1980s and 1990s Trump lost a lot
of money you got him guys I guess he's
not president anymore
I mean I can't believe that you've
uncovered the great secret about
President Trump that President Trump is
not as rich as he says he is and that he
has long been financially a sort of con
man who pastes his name on the outside
of giant buildings that lose money but
is great at branding you got him
nobody's ever brought this up before
nobody nobody's ever mentioned that this
guy somehow lost money in the casino
industry and then he has a bunch of
bankrupt companies nobody's ever
mentioned that so now that you got him I
am sure he will lose in 2020 you have
burst the bubble fellas my goodness
there's an article from Ross Buettner
and Susan
Craig and this was getting all the press
this morning until the assertion of
executive privilege the piece from the
New York Times says by the time his
master of the universe memoir Trump the
art of the deal had bookstores in 1987
Donald Trump was already in deep
financial distress losing tens of
millions of dollars on trouble business
deals
according to previously unrevealed
figures from his federal income tax
returns Trump was propelled to the
presidency in part by a self spun
narrative of business success and of
setbacks triumphantly overcome he's
attributed his first run of reversals
and bankruptcies to the recession that
took hold in 1990 but ten years of tax
information obtained by The Times paints
a different and far Bleecker picture of
his deal-making abilities and financial
condition the data printouts from
Trump's official IRS tax transcripts
with the figures from his federal tax
form from the 1040 for the years 1985 to
1994 represents the fullest most
detailed book to date at the president's
taxes information he has kept from the
public view the numbers show and in 1985
Trump reported losses of 46 point 1
million dollars from his core businesses
casinos hotels retail space and
apartment buildings they continued to
lose money every year totaling 1.17
billion in losses for the decade in fact
year after year Trump appears to have
lost more money than nearly any other
individual American taxpayer The Times
found when it compared his results with
detailed information the IRS compiles on
an annual sampling of high-income
earners
his core business losses in 1990 and
1991 more than 250 million dollars each
year were more than double those of the
nearest tax payers in the IRS
information for those years
overall Trump lost so much money that he
was able to avoid paying income taxes
for eight of the ten years it is not
known whether the IRS later required
changes after audits the White House's
response to the findings has shifted
over time several weeks ago a senior
official
issued a statement saying the president
got massive depreciation and tax shelter
because of large-scale construction and
subsidized developments this is why the
president has always scoffed at the tax
system and said you need to change the
tax laws on Saturday a lawyer for the
president wrote the tax information was
demonstrably false and that the paper
statements about the president's tax
returns and businesses from 30 years ago
are highly inaccurate and then he added
the IRS transcripts particularly before
the days of electronic filing are
notoriously inaccurate that would not be
able to provide a reasonable picture of
any taxpayers return so a couple of
things here No
one so what number two when it comes to
the president's image I love they say he
has a self spun image as this great deal
maker and very rich man
really was itself spun or did some
people help him out in the media guys
there are a lot of people who portray
themselves as very wealthy we're not in
fact very wealthy actually a fairly
regular thing in the United States and
Europe as well a lot of people who are
bankrupts who have yachts but does that
mean that the press didn't help him out
NBC put him on air for years claiming
that he was the greatest businessman in
America if it had not been for The
Apprentice Donald Trump is probably not
president right now and now you guys are
like wow Donald Trump what a con man I'm
sure he got him now President Trump this
doesn't answer the question as to why
President Trump doesn't want his tax
returns released it's always what I had
thought and I had been positing for
years the president doesn't want his tax
returns out there because he's not as
rich as he says he is he's not worth 10
billion dollars he may not even be worth
1 billion dollar does that matter at
this point the answer of course is no
the president though has tied his ego to
the public perception of his wealth and
so he tweets out real estate developers
in the 1980s and 1990s more than 30
years ago were entitled to massive
write-offs in depreciation which would
if one was actively building show losses
and tax losses in almost all cases much
was non-monetary some sometimes
considered tax shelter he would get it
by building or even buying you always
wanted to show losses for tax purposes
almost all real estate developers did
and often renegotiate with banks it was
sport
additionally the very old information
put out as a highly inaccurate fake news
hit job was gonna have to choose between
it's inaccurate and also I did all these
things also he's gonna have to choose
between yes I was using legitimate tax
shelters and - I was exaggerating my
losses for purposes of taxes which would
be tax fraud suffice it to say none of
this is going to damage the president's
in any serious way and the fact that
Democrats continue to pretend that
yelling at Trump about his wealth is
somehow going to take him down is really
really silly it's really absurd alright
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like I have started watching the HBO
series Chernobyl which is about of
course the Chernobyl incident from the
1980s in the Soviet Union a nuclear
meltdown that has provided the impetus
for a slowdown in the building of
nuclear nuclear power plants which is
absurd
if you are involved in the green
movement if you would like a green new
deal the first place you should begin is
with nuclear power plants that represent
a great plurality of the power provided
in for example France
the reason Chernobyl melted down is
because it was in one of the worst
places on planet Earth the Soviet Union
and was botched from beginning to end
but the series itself basically shows
that here's a little bit of the preview
for Chernobyl the good we did it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter is that to them
justice was done see the just world is a
sane world
[Music]
there was nothing sane about your mother
I'm pleased to report that situation in
Chernobyl is table in terms of radiation
I'm told it's the equivalent of a chest
x-ray
no Chernobyl is on fire
and every atom of uranium is like a
bullet
penetrating everything in its path it's
really horrifying and again it
demonstrates that third world countries
the USSR was treated as a developed
nation because it spends all of its
income on weaponry pointed at the United
States but the fact is that the Soviet
Union effectively was a third world
country and the and this was proof of it
the fact that that environmentalist have
used Chernobyl and North or Three Mile
Island as an example of why nuclear
power should no longer be engaged in is
true foolishness
again there's communist Nations not
famous for running well ok other things
that I like today so Georgia has now
passed the right-to-life Act it prevents
abortion it's basically a heartbeat bill
it prevents abortion after the sixth
week which is when a heartbeat can
usually first be detected here is
governor Bryan company who legitimate
duly elected governor of Georgia Stacey
Abrams talking about the right-to-life
Act this deserves all of our applause
some may challenge it in the court of
law but our job is to do what is right
not what is easy we are called to be
strong and courageous and we will not
back now we will always continue to
fight for life ok so this is great stuff
amazingly of course you have the entire
left unified an outrage that babies are
being saved so you've got Alexandra
Ocasio Cortes tweeting out six weeks
pregnant equals two weeks late on your
period okay well if you consider a
pregnancy the equivalent the moral
equivalence with just being late on your
period I have something called science
to show you this is a developing human
life by every scientific measure she
says most of the men writing these bills
don't know the first thing about a
woman's body outside of the things they
want from it I've always found this
contention particularly odd and what men
desperately want from women is for them
to be pregnant there's a sexist men what
they desperately want is for women to be
pregnant that's why men go to strip
clubs with pregnant ladies obviously men
love when women are pregnant just their
favorite thing in the world like it's
it's this is one of the dummer
contentions that the left makes all the
time first of all this bill was written
by three women
she also says it's relatively common for
to have a late period and not be
pregnant so this is a backdoor ban it's
not a backdoor ban it's a ban pretty
front-door actually like they're just
saying it as far as the idea that women
need more time to detect whether they're
pregnant so they can kill that baby I'm
pretty certain that the pro-lifers are
not concerned with when a woman becomes
aware that she is pregnant as much as
they are with the protection of the
unborn fetus it is also worth noting
that by this point in the pregnancy
there are arms and legs forming fingers
and toes and a heartbeat in that the
moral blindness of all of this is truly
astonishing
it truly is but I guess that you can
convince yourself of anything if you're
on the hardcore left so Christine Quinn
who who's a pro-choice activists on the
execrable Chris Cuomo's CNN show Chris
Cuomo is a super objective journalist he
loves journalism in just everywhere he
journalism's Christine Quinn says that's
not a human being inside a pregnant
woman I think she's been watching alien
too many times when a woman gets
pregnant that is not a human being
inside of her it's part of her body and
this is about a woman having full agency
and control of her body and making
decisions about her body and what is
part of her body with medical
professionals those are the facts and
that is from law a listen okay this is
the it's not a part it's a part of her
body it's not an independent human life
and this is just absurd it's just absurd
okay time for other things that I hate
cuz that is obviously a thing that I
hate Seth Meyers is garbage Seth Meyers
is he's supposed to be a comedian he's
not a comedian he is a late-night
propagandist for the DNC he used to
write comedy for Barack Obama so this is
not somebody who's a comedian
first and foremost at one time he was
somewhat funny as the as the weekly
correspondent on Saturday Night Live no
longer he has not been for a long while
last night he interviewed Megan McCain
and decided to attack her why because
Megan McCain had quoted Ilhan Omar and
that's very bad according to Seth Meyers
here was Seth Meyers with Megan McCain
who treats him with the appropriate
amount of outrage and disdain Megan
McCain is doing yeoman's work out there
here is Seth Meyers making the fool
self and megan mccain properly
demonstrating this way for people to
talk about differences in israeli policy
without getting framed as anti-semitic
language yeah i just think you can't
talk about jews hypnotizing the world
talking about all about the Benjamins
he's bringing up the two tweets that
she's apologized for and i think that's
a little unfair to her especially
because we've established what are you
were a press person no I'm just someone
who cares about the fact that there's
someone out there who is uh in a
minority who has had death threats
against her and I think that we should
all use the same language that you're
asking her to be careful about her
language and I would ask everybody else
to be careful about theirs okay that's
just you have to be careful about your
language really careful about your
language she needs to be careful about
her language and she's apologized first
of all she did not apologize for her
latest round of anti-semitism she sided
with Hamas during the last outbreak of
violence in the Gaza Strip she has
refused to apologize several times for
many of her remarks including her
downplaying of 9/11 Seth Meyers doing
this this kind of woke scold be careful
about your language Meghan McCain she
quoted Ilhan Omar that is not the same
thing as Ilhan Omar saying that the Jews
hypnotized the world or that people who
are pro-israel are suffering from dual
loyalty or that Americans are pro-israel
because of Jim money and it's not the
same thing Ilhan omar said a bunch of
bad stuff she continues to say bad stuff
she downplayed terrorism in 2016 and
2013 she made light of 9/11 on tape in
front of an organization that was a
unindicted co-conspirator in the Holy
Land Foundation terrorism trial and here
is Seth Meyers supposed comedian lecture
you know I just have to lecture you
Megan McCain about your very bad
language because you know she's been the
victim of death threats and if you quote
her I have a question really true
question so last week the FBI arrested a
human they arrested a human because this
human was making overt death threats
against people ranging from Jared
Kushner to Donald's from junior some of
these death threats were directly
directly sent to me right I mean they
were sent at me there were since one of
my employees they directly said that
this person wanted to blow my brains out
this person was posting publicly that
somebody should kill me and if you go
check the 8chan boards on this guy you
go check the reddit boards on this guy
all the comments underneath are well
this guy just shouldn't have said this
publicly you should have just go on and
done it we don't know why he had done
if he had shot Shapiro it's funny I have
not received a single question from I
have a lot of friends who work in
mainstream media I have not received aa
question not one zero questions from
anybody in the mainstream media about
inciting about incitement and inciting
language against me that results in that
sort of death threat not one incredible
where are they I mean I thought that if
you say bad stuff about somebody then
that's incitement of violence against
them that's what I learned from Ilhan
Omar that's how I've learned that Donald
Trump quoting her is an incitement to
violence against her because she's
received death threats so you shut your
face and yet when I receive not only a
death threat a death threats so bad that
the FBI gets involved and then arrests
somebody and when I receive that sort of
done when I have full round-the-clock
security full time okay I have full
around-the-clock security all the time
so just note two people who would
potentially try to hurt me or my family
you do that you're getting shot I've got
full around-the-clock security full-time
because of death threats and yet the
media have receive asked not a question
a question about incitement which
suggests to me that they don't actually
give a damn about incitement but they
gave a damn about incitement al Sharpton
would not be sitting on MSNBC now
Sharpton was involved linguistically in
helping to incite a riot and Crown
Heights against Jews in 1991 and incite
the burning down of Freddy's fashion
Mart in New York City and he sits on
MSNBC right now and we didn't have a
conversation about Bernie Sanders
inciting violence after the
Congressional baseball shooting did we
or Barack Obama inciting violence after
the Dallas police shooting I have a very
clear standard I think when people
criticize me it's not in citement I
think when people suggest I should be
shot that is incitement but Seth Meyers
doesn't have that standard Seth Meyers
is standard is if you criticize xel-há
Omar you are responsible for violent
death threats against her that's a bunch
of crap
it's a bunch of nonsense and he knows
it's nonsense and the fact that he's
accusing Megan McCain who has fought
against president Trump's originally
stated Muslim ban his actual ban on
immigration is not a Muslim ban specific
only five of the seven countries named
on that ban legally speaking are Muslim
most of most Muslim countries still can
send people here obviously but his
originally stated statement about we
need a shutdown on Muslim emigration all
of that Megan McCain opposed that Megan
McCain
as far as I know defended it on Omar's
right to where he shot down the floor
and the Congressional rules were changed
because of that so did I but Meghan
McCain is an islamaphobe according to
Seth Meyers who incites violence because
he likes ohon Omar now why remembers the
Democratic Party doing this why are
democratic hacks partisan tools like
Seth Meyers doing this sort of thing
unfunny clap tower advocates
why are they doing this because here is
the dirty little secret about the
Democratic Party and anti-semitism they
do not give a damn so long as they are
politically allied with the anti-semites
they do not care which is why all 20
Democratic presidential candidates said
nothing as Hamas a terrorist group that
hates America and hates Israel and calls
for the extermination of Jews across the
world fired 700 rockets into civilian
areas south my ears got anything to say
about that about incitement about
violence nothing now you're just mad at
Megan McCain man go perform some
unspeakable acts on yourself because
that is just what what what utter
nonsense the reality is that the
Democratic Party and too many Democrats
these days are not willing to face up to
the anti-semitism in their own party
because they are perfectly comfortable
with anti-zionism and are perfectly
unwilling to condemn anti-zionism as
anti-semitism and they don't care if
there are anti-semites in their own
party ranging from Al Sharpton to OHANA
Maher to Rasheeda Talib they do not give
any dams about that so long as they feel
they can make hay while the Sun shines
if you're not willing to condemn
anti-semitism across the board then you
don't care about anti-semitism and if
you are playing active defense for Ilhan
Omar and pretending that she oh it's
just a couple little tweets guys who's
just a couple she backs Hamas in the
list Kasich conflict I don't know any
other way to put that every Democratic
presidential candidate has said zero
things about Israel's right to defend
itself from attacks on civilian centers
by a group that calls for genocide
against Jews in their charter yeah I'm
sure Seth Meyers takes incitement real
seriously all right we'll be back here a
little bit later today for another two
hours of content otherwise we'll catch
you here tomorrow with more breakdown
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show Breaking major New York
Times investigative exclusive Donald
Trump was poor in the late 80s and early
90s the only other way you could have
found this breaking information is if
you read the whole book he wrote about
it or watched even one episode of his
show or read any newspaper in the 90s
will uncover the story at Daily wire
calm